So in our practice, I think this is under-appreciated UTIs.
I guess 44 million patients.
10 million doctor visits per year, 44, yeah, but maybe worldwide.
10 million doctor visits per year for UTIs.
We know they're common, right?
Now we have a solution to help these people,
these women mostly, this 44% of them
build up with a second UTI within six months,
which is absolutely unacceptable.
These poor women are going through this and it affects
affects your life, affects your gut, you have to go on antibiotics,
it affects your intimacy.
It's really something that we now have this turnkey product
that can really help to get a leg up on this.
So I would just say number one for me,
it's been more of a questioning my patients,
making sure that I'm not missing that.
Or if I read it on paper, we're going,
wait a minute, because these chronic infections,
they just take down your immune system.
There's only so many things to fight.
So I'm being more cognizant of my patients,
especially if they're women, saying this problem for you,
I have a solution for you, so that's number one thing.
What we're getting at too is that the bacteria
in these women who it's recurring is embedding
into their bladder wall.
So it's hiding in the bladder wall.
And then when, you know,
insult comes where they're having inner core,
so their immune system's down a little bit.
The bacteria come out and they'll get that full
of an infection.
You just chase it and chase it in your antimicrobials,
your antibiotics are just not working as well anymore.
At all, even I saw that when I was practicing traditional medicine.
Pauline blotter.
Pauline blotter, I know, right?
So Cranzyme, Cranzyme was created.
It's a turnkeyed product for women or men.
I just put a 90 year old nursing home patient on Cranzyme
to help because he has a catheter
and he was getting infections every six weeks,
was causing increased confusion.
And I mean, he was angry and it's just a lot of malaise.
So this has really helped him.
We're gonna talk about that key study.
They make a comment and we'll have you on that too.
With your see any elderly people,
they don't typically get symptoms of like bladder issues.
They just get upset and angry.
And you think it's part of their dementia,
that they have a UTI.
So that is like with anything over 80
that has any early dementia,
they won't get symptoms of urinary issues.
Meaning like you did it when you were 40 with a UTI.
Your symptoms are cognitive issues.
They'll be upset.
They're more angry.
They're more brain fog.
Their dementia just instantly got worse and too lazy
to think, oh my gosh, they just lit down the hill.
And they got a UTI.
Great, awesome point, that's a great point.
And then you think to the people over 80,
they're not drinking enough water.
I mean, they're just setting themselves up for you
to have some of them in the elderly capitors.
So Cranzyme is really a powerful probiotic,
which is a sun fiber.
We have the cranberry extract.
And then we put in some nato kinase.
That was Jason's really nice addition to this.
So the pro apple sign, it's a PACS,
those are available in the cranberry extract
is combined with the sun fiber.
So sun fiber is awesome for your gut health.
So then you have, you're not only strengthening
and getting rid of the problem and helping
to not have the bacteria in bad.
You're also strengthening the gut.
And the gut is so foundational that I just loved.
I love this product because it has that sun fiber in it.
So that's showing that the pathogenic bacteria,
they're not able to hear that lighter wall anymore,
which is really the problem.
That's that recurrence 44%, that's a lot.
That's again, that's unacceptable.
Bring the signs to the doctors.
Take care of it now, that's fine here.
So again, that prebiotics stimulates the gut bacteria,
minimize the harmful effects of bacteria.
And then the nato kinase is an enzyme
that has natural probiotic effects.
It eliminates bacteria's ability to attach
to the urinary tract and it can break up the mucus
because some of those infections are real mucusy.
It can really help deal with that.
And also in the protocol, if someone has an all-out UTI
and you feel like you catch it early
and it's not something that will kill them,
like in an elderly, you gotta act pretty quick.
You compare it with the sea sign.
So the sea sign, again, is all about the mucus
and really help clean that up, helping put that pain
of that urinary tract infection.
So Jason, I can share that protocol with you.
It's, you know, it's again, there's no protocols really
in my office, so it's more of what's work for them.
But typically, it's one to two, the crann sign
and then pair it with one to two of the sea sign.
Are you playing with it, with any people
that get care course from?
All right, cool.
Is this the one?
Here, we'll do the interesting part.
I know a moment.
Yes, you're the nine-year-old.
Yeah, awesome.
I had to slow her down, right?
So I had a 33-year-old who had probably, goodness.
15 UTIs in her lifetime, at least.
And she just go abstinent, which just didn't work
for her husband at all.
So she just dealt with it.
And it wasn't until I was like, hey, you know what?
She said something like, I just finished up an antibiotic
and I was like, wait a minute, sort of asking her.
She's like, yeah, I get a UTI every time we have inner horse.
Every time, and she's like, it's kind of really
putting a damper on my mirror.
She's like, I'm embarrassed, I don't know.
And I'm like, well, this is what we're going to do.
So I placed her on two crayons on before and after
inner course, and then one in the morning.
And I think she ended up taking it for three mornings
and a rope, which she just wanted to take it.
And then she had no symptoms.
And that was probably six, seven weeks ago now, baby.
When I close that, she's still doing well,
and her husband's really happy.
So, Kelly, do you see there's a correlation
with having to do something with the spouse as well?
You know, not at this, I keep that in mind.
Sometimes I'll have them do like an ozone cream
all over the general area, just to kind of like regulate it out.
But as far as putting them on, I haven't done that yet.
I look at the treating the spouse as well.
Yeah, that's a great idea.
Yeah, right.
There's a lot more fouls.
That's just not a little fouls, is that?
Yeah, a lot more fouls.
Never mind.
And all is numb.
Thank you, thank you.
You're welcome.
It's a serious matter.
I don't know if it's really good.
Yeah, that's a great idea.
That's a great idea.
It's a great idea.
So then this is that nursing home patient
started to have some increased dementia.
I got really angry, and so they checked his urine
sure enough.
Another UTI, put them on the crayon's eye
and that the dose was two at the onset of symptoms.
And he did have some, I think he had some burning,
a little bit of burning.
And so for him, the burning went away
and he went back to his baseline, which is nice.
So I brought that up, and now he's on one every day.
So we're going to see what that takes us.
He might have to go to two every day.
It's helping his gut too, so I don't mind going up.
The only caveat that I come across
is that someone has a problem with oxalates.
I don't know, theoretically, it could become a problem.
I mean, like at a really higher dose,
Mel, do you have any insight on that?
Because you did okay.
I don't know how your dose, it wasn't.
And it wasn't.
It wasn't long to me, it was like today.
Yeah, it's not for an extended treatment.
Right, I wouldn't.